[Music]
welcome to max tech
and this is our review of the iphone 12
[Music]
pro
on the surface the iphone 12 pro seems
like it's basically the same phone from
last year
just with an updated design and a couple
of added features
but in reality it's actually the biggest
generational leap since the iphone 6s
which was such a solid phone that apple
struggled for years
trying to get people to upgrade to a
newer iphone
so in this review i'm going to explain
why the iphone 12
pro is so good that it's following in
the 6s footsteps
hello and welcome back going back to
apple's iphone event
a lot of people were quite disappointed
with the iphone 12 lineup
saying that nothing has really changed
but that's far from the truth
just like the iphone 11 pro from last
year the iphone 12
pro ended up being so much better than i
expected
when i finally got my hands on it and
started testing it out
in fact there are so many improvements
that apple didn't mention
during the event so in this review
instead of just giving you guys
all the specs you've already heard in
other reviews like the new 814 bionic
chip
the lidar scanner the six gigs of ram
and
everything else i'm gonna talk about the
things that actually
matter in everyday life and i'm also
gonna talk about the most controversial
topics
like the real reason why apple got rid
of the power adapter and the wired
earbuds
that used to come inside of the box and
also the whole thing about 5g
and battery life which a lot of people
are misunderstanding
and throwing under the bus so let's get
right into it this year
things are a bit different because i
can't order the 12
pro max that i want until next month
but i did buy my wife the 6.1 inch 12
pro which she's been using for the past
week
so for this review i asked her if she
noticed anything different coming from
her iphone 11 pro
and i was shocked by the amount of
improvements that she noticed
but before we get into that i want to
talk about why i think the iphone 12
pro is so great that it's easily worth
upgrading from an older iphone
maybe even the iphone 11 pro i
personally believe that there are
three reasons why people should upgrade
to a new phone
and the iphone 12 pro completely nails
all three of them the first one is that
the phone has to feel
different because when you're spending
this much money
you don't want it to feel like your
previous phone that exact reason
is why so little people upgraded from
the iphone 10
to the iphone 10s they were so similar
that you couldn't even tell them apart
but when i first got the iphone 12 pro
in my hands
i was completely blown away because it
feels like a totally
different phone and i'm reminded of that
every time i pick it up
yes that's due to the new flat sides
which apple
executed perfectly the edges are
barely rounded into the flat sides but
at the same time
both the glass on the front and the
glass on the back
are perfectly flush with the stainless
steel band
seriously if you haven't held the iphone
12 in your hands
you have to go find one because it feels
so much
better than you'd expect my wife was
initially stunned by the new design
but after a couple of days she fell in
love
with their iphone 12 pro saying that
it's so much
easier to hold and she absolutely loves
how clean and smooth
the new design looks being flat all the
way around
and because the front glass is also now
completely flat apple was able to make
the bezels
quite a bit more thin and thanks to
bumping up the display to 6.1 inches
my wife told me that she loves how much
more immersive
the display in the phone feels and on
top of that apple has improved the
speakers
being louder and sounding better than
the ones on the iphone 11 pro
which were already a massive improvement
compared to older iphones
so this really helps it feel like you
have a totally different phone
now the second reason why people should
upgrade to a new phone is
reliability yes we've got the new a14
bionic chip which is
the fastest iphone chip ever obviously
but honestly it doesn't really make the
iphone
feel any faster than before and like i
say
every single year the performance
differences actually go
directly towards efficiency and camera
improvements
which i'll get into in just a minute one
major thing i complained about last year
was that the 11 pro still only had
four gigabytes of ram and that led to
apps closing in the background
which was extremely annoying but now the
iphone 12 pro
finally has 6 gigs of ram and so far i
haven't experienced any issues yet
we also now have the ceramic shield
front glass
which is supposed to have much better
drop protection
and since i use my iphones naked without
a case
this gives me a lot of extra peace of
mind and now
let's get into all of that 5g and
battery life controversy
yes the battery is quite a bit smaller
than it was
last year and that's because apple had
to make the iphone quite a bit thinner
so the squared off edges don't make it
feel too thick
and because of the smaller battery the
12 pro now gets about one hour less of
battery life
compared to the iphone 11 pro according
to mr who's the boss
and i think it's because of the a14's
killer graphics performance
which demands more power in the antutu
graphics test
that he was running but considering the
fact that the display is now
larger 6.1 inches compared to the
previous 5.8
it's actually not too bad of a hit and
that brings us to the controversy of
5g which can lead to even worse battery
life
but there are two very good solutions
that people
aren't talking about or at least they're
misunderstanding
apple created the smart data mode which
only turns on 5g
when you actually need it which means
that you could potentially
go through a full day without 5g being
turned on
even once which means that it doesn't
impact battery life at
all now i know what you're gonna say
what's the point of upgrading if it's
not even using
5g well this might surprise you
but the even bigger deal is the fact
that apple
is finally using qualcomm's snapdragon
x55 modem in the new iphone 12 lineup
and this new modem
is the real game changer so here are a
couple of screenshots i took
using my iphone 11 pro and the new 12
pro in my basement
and as you can see the reception is
terrible
on my 11 pro and simply switching to the
12 pro using
lte i got 25 times faster download
speeds
and 5g was actually slower because it
doesn't seem to penetrate into basements
that well
i then went upstairs and now 5g is
actually giving us a huge advantage
as high as 87 megabits per second
using t-mobile's low band 5g which is
basically
everywhere in my city and not the
millimeter wave 5g
which i think shouldn't even matter
because you can move a couple of feet
and lose millimeter wave and now while
upstairs in my house the lte on the 12
pro isn't much faster than the 11 pro
for download speeds the upload speeds
improved quite a bit as well
so here's the thing about 5g and the new
iphones
if you're worried about battery life
just turn
off 5g and enjoy very reliable lte
speeds that are now much faster as you
guys saw in my basement
not only that but after only a week my
wife has already noticed much better
cellular service
all over town including a friend's house
where she always struggled with bad
service on her previous iphone 11 pro
but now this qualcomm modem is a game
changer
without even considering 5g so i ended
up simply
turning off 5g on my wife's iphone 12
pro
because she honestly doesn't like 5g and
she would much
rather have better battery life instead
now let's finally get into the third
reason why i think
people should upgrade to a new phone and
that's the feature set
i think one of the biggest deals for the
iphone 12 lineup is
the new mac save feature apple basically
created
a new ecosystem of accessories that can
more conveniently attach to the iphone
using magnets like of course the mac
safe wallet
that i'm still patiently waiting for
there are also now pop sockets that are
coming to the iphone 12
no longer requiring a sticky adhesive to
hold on
car mounts are about to become so much
more convenient
with magnets built into the iphone
itself and there are so many
possibilities that we haven't realized
yet
since this is the first week since the
iphone 12 has been released
and i honestly believe that after a full
year the market is gonna be flooded
with magsafe accessories and this
feature itself
is gonna get people to upgrade now
beyond that
the absolute number one feature that i
didn't expect to get
improved this much is the camera
performance
that was the one thing that my wife
wouldn't stop talking about
she was so impressed by how every photo
looked more
sharp on the iphone 12 pro especially
the ultra wide camera which looks so
much better than before
and this is odd because it's literally
the same exact camera sensor and lens
from the 11 pros ultrawide camera the
big difference
is in the new software improvements we
now have smart hdr3
which uses ai to optimize various parts
of the scene
we also now have night mode on every
single camera
which is a game changer because you'd be
limited to the wide lens on the 11 pro
if you wanted great looking nighttime
shots
and now selfies look amazing in the dark
even pitch black as you can see right
here
and on top of that the iphone 12 pro
comes with a new
lidar scanner which is basically like an
upscaled version of face id
that helps with 3d depth mapping and
tracking
the lidar scanner enables nighttime
portrait photos
which we've never had before because
portrait shots require much more light
and as you can tell these photos turn
out great
but what you might not know is that the
iphone 12 pro actually uses the lidar
scanner
for video recording in the dark as well
check out the difference between these
three generations of
iphones the iphone 10s doesn't even try
to focus
while the 11 pro hunts for focus
non-stop
but the 12 pro gets it spot on every
time
thanks to using the lidar scanner but
the absolute
biggest deal of all is getting deep
fusion on
every single camera including the selfie
camera
it basically takes multiple photos in
the blink of an eye
and then combines the data from multiple
photos
into one compressing the detail
into a tightly packed and incredibly
sharp photo
that's why everything from ultrawide
photos to zoom
shots and even selfies look so much more
detailed than before
even though the actual megapixels of the
sensors
haven't changed and i need to remind you
that all of these major software
improvements
are possible because of the massive
performance improvement
of the a14 bionic chip since all of this
happens in real time
unlike other phones like the pixel 5
which makes you wait for seconds
to finish processing before you can see
things like the background blur and the
true dynamic range
apple wants this type of processing to
happen right away
and the a14 chip allows them to enable
processor heavy features
like deep fusion and smart hdr3 on all
of the lenses
so with all of that said the iphone 12
pro
absolutely nails the three things that i
believe
matter the most in terms of iphone
upgradability
and with that i want to finish with the
real reason why
apple didn't include a charger or wired
earbuds in the box
yes i guess in a way it does help the
environment
but it honestly helps apple much more
because they ditched the charger
and the earbuds they not only save money
on those two items
but they're now able to make every
iphone box
twice as small as before saving them
massive amounts of cash
in terms of material transportation
inventory and shipping costs not only
that but it forces people to buy
wireless air pods and a fast charger
which means
even more potential profit for apple now
while that makes them seem very
evil and greedy let me remind you
that apple kept the price of the iphone
12 pro
at the exact same 999 dollars
while adding a bunch of expensive
features
the top of the line 5g modem from
qualcomm definitely wasn't cheap
we now have 6 gigs of ram instead of 4
128 gigs of base storage instead of 64
a brand new flat edge design which
requires retooling
better water resistance a brand new 5
nanometer chip from tsmc
a brand new wide sensor from sony
new ceramic shield glass from corning a
new lidar scanner for the first time
ever
on any iphone and of course the new
magsafe
built right into the iphone we're
basically getting a lot of extra
features and hardware this year
at the exact same price while a lot of
other android phones
are getting more expensive thanks to 5g
support
or in the case of the pixel 5 which
sacrifices flagship specs
and features to save money instead apple
is giving us
brand new tech and top of the line
hardware for the same price as before
and they're sacrificing the charger and
earbuds to do it
which is actually okay with me because i
already have a fast charger
and i already have earpods like many
other people out there
so with all of that said let me wrap up
this review with the three
biggest reasons why anyone should
upgrade to the iphone 12 pro
fast and reliable lte cellular service
major camera improvements thanks to the
a14 bionic chip
and finally the new flat redesign which
makes it feel like you have
a totally different phone and that truly
matters for
upgradability so if you choose to
upgrade to an iphone 12
or 12 pro it's gonna feel modern for the
next few years
since the rounded side redesign of the
iphone 6
lasted for five generations before this
flat side design change so to be
completely honest
there has never been a better time to
upgrade to a new iphone
hopefully you guys enjoyed this review
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe
because i'm gonna be reviewing the
iphone 12 pro max
as soon as i get my hands on it next
month and also be sure to check out our
camera comparisons
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you
in the next one
you